they turn into the male equivalent of
feminists where they lose all their
rationality and become emotional and
they'll start making personal remarks
the exact same thing they accuse women
of doing they go to being personal when
they don't have a lot of logical
argument does the comment section
yeah but it doesn't bother me that they
Rose me they can say whatever they want
but the reality is it only happens when
I don't talk their language and they
have display the same emotional
dysregulation as a feminist they claim
to hate the feminists that say I hate
women all men are trash the red pill men
when you don't speak their language it
displayed the exact level of femininity
irrationality and personal remarks that
we are always told that women do I mean
I just think it's silly to go on the
internet and not expect to give bad
comments so so on both sides yeah on
both sides so it's like did you get hate
comments does that does that mean the
whole red pill movement when I've when I
I'm the one who knows all of the people
that lead the space I'm the one who's
met them you're basing your experience
off of the comment section